hello we made it
we made it thank you so much for joining
me today I hope you've been having a
wonderful time here at strange Loop uh
this my this is my first time at strange
Loop and I'm really thankful to be here
uh there's there's been amazing talks
over the years
um and really brilliant people doing
really amazing things so glad you're
you're with me and uh let's get this
show rolling so today
as you can see based on the title this
is what we're talking about we are in St
Louis is anybody here from here oh a lot
of you wow that's awesome oh man is
anybody uh both a con a computer person
and a musician that's here
oh wow that is awesome okay so I can see
where a lot of the interest comes from
that's that's great that's great okay
beautiful St Louis grateful to be here
my name is Ben uh I'm known as oh Ben
Source uh all over the web so if you
want to find me it's pretty easy to
remember uh this is me with a
internationalization working group for
node.js a couple years back in Berlin
um I have I'd say I've had two careers
in my life the first one was in music
and I toured and recorded worked in
recording studios and that's me
conducting a thing for another
conference a few years back and that was
really fun as well
and I've also been involved uh here and
there with computer music and web music
if anybody's familiar with computer
music it's one of my heroes this is John
chowning he discovered FM synthesis and
developed that
and then I have done that you know I've
done
community events for years and have been
a part of the web Community this is PDX
node node.js users group and then I also
work at datadog so I really care a lot
about observability and how to
understand what the heck is going on
under the surface with your actual users
and deployments and stuff like that
and
these are sort of the things that I've
been involved in over the years and
that's a little bit about me so before
we get into some fun software
experiments let's pull back just a
little bit and start here so today we
are exploring how making live music
together is evolving with the web that's
what we're going to be talking about
primarily kind of where it is where it's
going what's possible what's confusing
as hell so we'll get into that
um
yeah so uh before I start really quickly
I just want to see if it's a possibility
to do the demo that I was planning on
doing uh so I'm just going to check to
see if
no still okay
that's okay I I uh I have pre-recorded
something to share at the end so you can
kind of see where it has gone
um so yeah what I wanted to say here was
that live music has been a fundamental
thing uh for people ever since we could
make sounds with our mouths and hit
sticks and you know make make noise it
brings anyone together anywhere at any
time and when it happens we remember it
because it's at the root of how we
connect and relate to each other and
there's so much correlation between
connection and music and connection in
the messages that we see each other and
it's a beautiful thing
um over the past hundred years the way
that people have spent their time
connecting has drastically changed uh in
general and I think two historic moments
that are really worth remembering uh
today in terms of how they've impacted
how we think about making music together
is audio recording and much more
recently the pandemic
so audio recording technology introduced
musical events as artifacts to the
general public and that we could buy and
that's great but the trade-off is that
we began to think about music as sounds
and how they make us feel uh instead of
how sharing musical experiences together
brings us closer together
and more recently with covid it showed
us how we feel when we're not able to
gather together and engage with our
friends family and people around music
there was something missing
um and I bring all this up because I
think it's a pertinent back story to how
live music on the web is becoming a
recognized need and
so I think with that we should quickly
uh take a look at what networked live
music is
and how it came about how it brought us
together or how
just you know how it came about and how
it helps us share uh experiences
together in the web so briefly what is
it
um well over the uh about 20 years ago
Nick please just leave me alone now I'm
doing my talk okay
we'll push the change back to each of us
man oh it might work hey
all right all right let's see
um
okay A little over 20 years ago uh some
members from Stanford's Karma which is
their Center for computer computer
research and music and Acoustics they
describe Network musical performance as
a real-time interaction over a computer
network that enables musicians in
different locations to perform as if
they were in the same room together
um this has been the definition that
most people who care about this domain
are familiar with and kind of their
go-to definition uh but as we'll see
moving into this talk uh that may not be
the only way that we can make Network
live music happen
so how did we get to this juncture
anyway I think you should know about a
few faces for a little background as
well so
um the karma people
John shouting on the left there he
discovered and developed FM synthesis
procured the way that we experience
music on computers for decades if
anybody is old enough as old as me and
remembers things like Sound Blaster and
like stuff you know and FM chips and the
midi sound you know that everybody talks
about
um that happened that we wouldn't have
had music like that at that point in our
computers if it weren't for people like
John chowning
um and that was an extremely important
Milestone to get to where we are now uh
so then in the middle there we've got
Chris chaffe uh who is the director uh
at Karma he developed a low latency
audio streaming solution called jacktrip
uh and it works with uh it works on
Linux systems low latency uh low latency
audio focused kernel stuff and uh that
it runs on these it runs on these tiny
machines and people set them up and they
can play with uh like peer-to-peer with
relative low latency between each other
but it's in regions that are very near
um because of latency issues and things
we'll get into that in a little bit and
then on the right there's Jack triplabs
which is newer company that is
commercializing uh the work of jacktrip
uh it's most well known right now for
Eric Whitaker who has like a virtual
choir he used this about a year or two
years ago to perform like a mass choir
performance within about a 300 mile
radius of all the performers
uh really quickly the web audio people
so like web audio is about 10 years old
now which is crazy to me uh it's almost
10 years old and
um it's a standard that if you're not
familiar with it it's a web standard
that allows uh developers to access
Primitives in the browser that open up
sound synthesis so we're not talking
about like playing a [ __ ] playing a what
you can play an audiophile with it like
a wave or whatever but we're talking
about the synthesis and the physics of
sound using that in the browser making
synthesizers using midi to control those
synthesizers in your browser and that
sort of thing so if you it it doesn't
take much of a leap to go there's this
and the network what do we do you know
um so that's pretty cool and then um
yeah some notable people here Chris
Rogers who came who uh first proposed it
and then Hong Chan Choi as a friend of
mine uh amazing person who helped
develop things like the audio script uh
the the audio worklet which like makes
it really easy just to just to put audio
on a different thread in your browser
because uh the way that browsers work it
usually goes on the main thread with
JavaScript so there's one flow of
traffic you put other stuff on there
you're trying to do audio real time
it's not going to work right
he's helped make it easy to do complex
audio calculations on other threads and
whatnot
um you know those people have been
really worth mentioning because without
them this wouldn't you know making live
music in the browser wouldn't be
possible but what about this as a need
is it really a need you know like live
music is pretty cool people go to shows
now again and you know people seem to be
able to stream performances over YouTube
and whatnot you know like his if they
want to but is there really need for
this well there's definitely been some
significant interest in this domain and
it continues to grow with these awesome
projects that have come out in the last
uh you know three plus years Ableton
released link which is a local network
jam session because it's completely
doable over a local network
Zoom has a high fidelity music mode
which is really cool and a lot of people
use that to try to rehearse and practice
now and share ideas and whatnot so it's
definitely interesting in the the world
of zoom and then there's a few startups
that are trying to build Cloud
collaboration platforms on remote music
making like bandlab and sound trap and
session wire and Avid has one called
Cloud collaboration and of course
professional musicians are live
streaming performances over YouTube as I
mentioned and twitch and other platforms
um while you know while they're
performing from a central location
so
as we can see with all these different
methods and tools for doing this now
the two desired outcomes that are
present that we can see are jamming like
people really want to be able to jam
right they want to be in the same place
playing together and that's awesome but
they also have a desire to deliver a
live performance like can we just
deliver it and not have to be in the
same place that would be so awesome how
do you know is there is that a tool that
we can get
um
and the tools that support these
activities you know they're going to
grow
but it's still really early days for web
audio and
um
to make increasingly useful progress in
this domain we have to keep learning
about how to navigate through the craft
of the browser and the network and all
the things that come into play to keep
that contribute to latency and um and
then we also need to remember to have
fun because all of this
has been spurred on like I I think that
most of you are here because maybe you
said like oh yeah there's a lot of these
Tech this might this one will probably
be fun you know what I mean
like yeah there you go right because
music is fine it it hits it
it hit it hits something that's core
like it's not tied up uh in and of
itself in like in like a comp one
company or commercialism or whatever
like I'm not trying to sell you anything
We're just trying to do something fun
because we're humans we love to do it
together right and things are going to
get better and we can we can get there
over time but we need to remember to
have fun and so that's that's how this
project started uh with me so what what
is browser music and what does it look
like
um
as we've already seen you know
everything to date has been dependent on
this Jam room idea jacktrip that I
mentioned seems to be the closest
realization to like a jam room within
that context uh with with their app
um but what are the constraints for
something like that if you want to do a
jam room today well there's
bi-directional latency so
um
you have to start thinking about things
like
time like a lighter light over distance
over the network if I go uh I have a
figure later on on another slide but
over over 100 miles it like adds 20 it
adds like a few milliseconds of latency
for each hop right and so the more you
do that if you're trying to play this
with someone and they're trying to play
back this way to you the further apart
you are uh you're gonna like if if
you're like a thousand miles apart it's
going to sound like you know you're
playing with a really bad drummer or
like you know or like your guitarist
can't keep up or whatever and so like
that's not kind of what that's not what
you want in this sort of situation but
um and it's hard to tell uh what all the
variables are at times
um yeah but we'll get there so um for
Jack trip it's about three to four
hundred miles
so even with low latency audio and
bi-directional like fast streaming of of
audio events and whatnot or audio sound
it just sorry I've been doing a lot with
midi so I'm thinking in terms of Events
audio buffer data you know sending
across the wire
um it breaks down after about 300 miles
400 miles because then that delay starts
to get enough to to not make it be
cohesive to be able to to play together
because of physics but also I would say
much more like we're talking about
physics physics of light but we're also
talking about the physics we're talking
about like the architecture that we're
working with and all the little unknowns
that are in between there's everything
from what's out there hopping over a
network to what's right in front of you
like you try to do web audio and uh I've
been running into issues like when I
navigate away from the browser and I
have an audio context playing sound you
know because somebody's playing uh and I
go to like Zoom to talk to them it stops
because the browser's like hey you can't
play audio if you're not looking at me
you know what you know so you have to go
and programmatically say resume here
resume here you know and you're like
stuff like that so there's there's a lot
of stuff that can get in the way
um I was this this is all about like
what you know why why isn't on the web
yet because the web is supposed to be
this Fantastical place of everything is
amazing but it's you know
um it sometimes
often can be if you want it to be okay
uh so let's talk about the inherent
constraints of of uh of uh browser music
here so
um
if you're trying to recreate the jam
room standard web browsers and web apis
can't really perform this as well as a
standalone like specialized low latency
application that's either run on
Hardware like Jack drip or whatever
um uh and other inherent issues that
come with using like Chrome you know the
different platforms and chromium and all
that
um so like in a browser at best I don't
know if you saw Google's shared piano
experiment but a couple years ago but at
best you can probably do something like
this and get away with it and it can be
fun what this is is you know people are
able to connect from anywhere and play
notes on a piano and have it relatively
sound like it's in in time because
there's it's small enough that uh you
know in the data is small enough and
just the
it'll still break up with latency over
distance and all that but that's about
like what you can do in the web to get
people together and I have something
similar that we'll be doing uh in just a
minute
um because I think I think that one will
work
um so but I what I submit to you today
is that there are other ways of
recreating a jam room or not a jam room
there's other ways of recreating uh uh
live music
and that's fundamental to delivering a
musical performance and it doesn't have
to be a jam room
um but it's it's just another tool that
can be leveraged to make live music work
in the browser so before we get into
that we should probably ask ourselves
what do we actually want uh with with
live music
so live distributed musical experiences
of course is one right we want to be
able to say we want to be able to gather
people together and do something and
have it go somewhere and other people
can enjoy it we can enjoy it while we're
doing it
um and this is Eric Whitaker with his
choir uh virtual choir
using jacktrip or you might want to
create uh be ex you know you might want
to have musical parameters from a live
performance exposed to the up
you can play it you can tap in and play
along with uh with the performance and
um
be an integrated part of the event so
with that if this goes
we can we can we can do that I don't
know if anybody has oh man so I think
this is going to be like a laptop only
probably
um so if anybody has a laptop
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna see I'm
gonna see if this works I'm gonna talk
to my friend Nick
you'll just have to deal with the
warning messages
okay no problem
uh
uh okay wait hmm all right push changes
I need to redeploy okay all right okay
well let's see if I can do that so I'm
gonna hop on the server here I'm gonna
kill it and then I'm going to
actually
this is like
just in time
here we go
pull request nothing he must have put it
on there okay so I'm gonna get pull
and
a boarding
no okay good status
get stash
get no yeah get pull
Ed okay let's see shall we okay
all right
okay that should be live let me check
and I'll go over to event mode
really oh maybe it's um
there we go okay
hello okay
okay all right here we go everyone okay
so I'm going to go back to that URL now
with this URL uh right here and sorry
it's about string of numbers did not
have time to set up DNS and stuff
um if you have uh it's going to be https
so do that and if you see something
that's like hey you can't do this like
on the browser then what you need to do
is type in I'm sorry it's annoying what
you need to do is type in in your
browser all one word all lowercase this
is unsafe
and it'll let you through
so that's what you do okay
okay now yeah
there's some people here
[Music]
so this is chromatic it's probably not
going to sound gorgeous or anything
but uh if you at least if you stay in
the middle Keys it should be like a
Dorian scale
and it only sounds like okay
[Music]
um
it actually sounds really cool
[Music]
works on mobile I didn't try bubble
that's great
and so my my original thought here was
that um
with since this got pushed out I didn't
have time to like bring in I have like a
synthesizer I was gonna set this up into
the sound system and be playing like
having you play and then be playing in a
Dorian mode as well and then have it be
a musical experience so what I'm trying
to show you right now is that we're just
using this over web sockets it's a
straight up like node websocket that's
it and so the time is actually not that
bad you're here in this room and it's
like just a little bit of delay that's
enough it's not it's at a place where
you could like if I expose parameters
for my synthesizer to you or I uh you
know or I did this where we're trying to
do like a musical Mosaic or something
and I set you in a certain scale you
would be able to uh to do that and so um
there you go that's uh that's the uh
that is the musical Mosaic there you go
and I'm gonna figure out how to kill
this before uh
I go on so I don't go crazy
okay
all right I think if I kill the server
it'll just yeah
killed the server that did it now I got
a hanging note okay there we go
all right that worked great that was fun
[Applause]
um
thank you for joining me with uh joining
me on that on that little journey um
that is something that
uh
similar to something I was able to do
a while ago and and it's just so fun
when you start to have people's presence
audible with you especially even in a
browser or whatever it is and uh to know
that we're all here and we're all doing
that and it's going to a place where we
can all hear it collectively is so it's
really cool even even if there is a
little bit of latency
so that was awesome okay thank you for
joining me with that let's go on to live
music so let's um let's ask let's do
find My Notes let's
talk about live music over the web and
approaches to enable it now this part's
going to get a little bit there's I I
think I put too many code slides in here
I'm going to like kind of go through
them don't I don't expect everyone to be
like
reading them all or whatever I'm just
going to try to explain to you like
what's going on what's important so uh
don't don't let it take up your
cognitive space I'll get through it so
uh the first thing I think that's worth
talking about is relays
um
I a few years ago came up with this it
just like kind of occurred to me or I
was like okay we're trying to do this
Jam room thing but that doesn't work
because of latency why are we going why
don't we just not solve that problem and
go one way how can we go one way and
deliver a performance so relays came to
mind so like
um if you have if you use a technology
like web sockets where you can easily
send messages to each other you don't
necessarily have the overhead of a
peer-to-peer Network which you can do it
that way but going One Direction if you
account for the latency in the uh of of
uh what I'm about to show you it doesn't
really matter if you're using time-wise
it doesn't really matter if you're using
peer-to-peer or web sockets but what's
going on here is that player one is
playing their performance uh and player
two is hearing player one this acts like
a recording session so in this model
unfortunately and there's ways to
explore presence and how to
um how to feel connected while you're
doing this but this will be very
familiar to anyone who's been in a
recording studio or been like you know
I'm going to create a live route for my
song I like if it's a guitar or whatever
and I'm singing or a keyboard I'm going
to build on that it's exactly the same
concept so like player one plays that
performance goes to player two player
two receives that plays along with that
goes to player three player three
receives the uh the sum of player one
and two's performance goes along to
player four who receives the sum of the
rest behind them and then that gets
broadcast either to a client to all the
clients and rendered over web audio or
you can send it out to MIDI devices or
whatever at a live venue which is great
um so with this little code sample here
I don't know if that's big enough if
it's not don't worry about it I'll
explain what's going on and we'll just
uh swinging through these here so
this is a this is uh I can share my
slides too afterwards if you want to
take a look at the code but there's just
a relay uh using web sockets so it's
really simple it does the same thing
it's like hey what's the next client
I've I've sorted my websocket uh clients
in order I'm going to pass it to the
next one great did they get it great now
I'm going to send it to the next one
after that send it to the next one as
the messages come in and the next uh
that that's relays the next thing I
think that's important to talk about uh
architecturally is event sampling and
Playback and I wrote a Blog on this if
you want to read this in detail it's on
my site open open source.com so if you
want to go there check it out please do
um because it explains it in detail
so event sampling and Playback is really
important what do I mean by that I mean
that in order to realist not
realistically in order to account for uh
all the inherent latency of playing
sending to the next person getting it on
time and lining it up using JavaScript
sampling and Playback seems to be the
the go-to method for this instead of
I've tried sending out just streaming
messages as they come
and that can get really hairy
um you know from browser to browser but
if you treat it like recording but do it
in short enough chunks that it's live it
becomes more alive like within the span
of uh you know 15 20 30 seconds uh
depending on how many you're playing and
then it's broadcast uh it's still within
your time kind of like you know General
uh broadcast where it's like eight
seconds or whatever before it gets sent
out
um so event sampling and Playback is
really key I don't expect you to be able
to see that but what's going on here is
that every five seconds uh a chunk of
events like sampled events while
somebody was playing is sent to the next
person and so uh
it's uh it count it calculates the time
uh for uh if it was five seconds after
they started playing and then it sends
it out to the next person and that
continues to go for every client and so
it's sampling uh using I'll get to that
like a sampling using request animation
frame and I'll explain why
um so then there's event playback so
when when a user receives uh the notes
what happens well
um that data gets looped through and
summed and like sorted in time based on
uh the time that it was sent but there's
another problem right like you can't
just send data from one client to
another like immediately you have to
count for the offsets of every client
and so with that you have to calculate
the offsets of of every client and so
that that was kind of a revelation to me
because when I first set this up and I
had things going from person to person
to person it was like like all the way
you know just down the line and it's
just like shotgunning
um you know like these notes okay well
that's not going to work right that's
not music so so and that's not in time
right so what do we do
um well calculating calculating the
offset by uh each connection like uh on
the on the websocket uh relays is what
you have to do so
um if you like here what I what I do is
I check for a global note offset
um and then like it's like when did they
start hearing the note right before that
and when do they start playing and then
it uh it kind of uh gets just the right
time uh to be able to start playing the
notes uh in time and summing them
together there's another one
um using you know using browser
Primitives like performance.now you can
figure out exactly you know on a high
resolution where you are at what time
and use that to create your calculations
uh and then play back accordingly okay
so that's a bunch of heady stuff you can
look at the blog if you want great the
next thing thing is midi so leveraging
many I chose to go the route of midi
first rather than
going the route of uh trying to to use
like waves and things like that and
trying to go with audio
because the notes themselves are like
one to three bytes per message and
they're super tiny and it's really easy
to um
it's really easy to to control and to
experiment with it does come with
constraints though you have to have a
note on and a note off and this has been
a long-term problem for Midi right so
like I'm sure you've if many musicians
in here if you've been like playing
along with something and you actually
turn your keyboard off or something
changes something and you're playing and
then Peter just go it just hangs that's
been a problem for like 40 years so with
it with like with midi it it's crazy
because midi is uh is a 40 year old uh
protocol believe it or not you can
connect like you can connect if you use
midi conversion to CV you can connect
like a synthesizer from the 60s to a
modern midi device and just play
everything fine it's it's amazing that
we can do this with like the age of
these devices and stuff so anyways yeah
note on Note off
still not a solved problem and it gets
funky with JavaScript here you have to
uh you have to send messages that your
midi devices can understand
uh by using string inter you know
extreme interpolation and whatever by
getting it in a hex
um getting it into a a hex number that
it can understand
um so yeah the last thing I want to
mention here about architectures
websockets
and websockets even though since we're
going One Direction it's not
peer-to-peer it's really easy to be able
to send different event types so you can
say like hey did you player join yes
they did okay everybody here's the new
player okay put you up on the
visualization or put you on the roster
or whatever so I have a function in here
called create roster or send roster
create roster that kind of thing that
always updates like who the players are
who's who's here and and positionality
right because we're doing it in a relay
so it's very important to establish with
your players with your band members that
uh what position you're in before you
start playing because if you were
expecting to hear you know something and
you're in position one you're not going
to hear it and if you were you know
expecting to hear the drummer the
drummer's in position three and you're
in position two you're not going to hear
the drummer right so you got it's like
you gotta play with it that way
um there there are limitations and
struggles
JavaScript is weird
it's a weird language I mean like this
is the one code sample I think I can
show but like
what what do I want here this is like
say this is my midi message and I have
three bytes that I want to send to a
midi device and I make my unit array
great now I'm going to stringify it so I
can send it over the wire and I want it
to just play nope it's their object now
why why is it an object now
so because I said Json stringify no and
arrays are objects in JavaScript I'm
sure people know but why who knows okay
so there's that javascript's weird so
you have stuff you got to deal with also
JavaScript timers are really tricky
um you cannot
depending on the context of what you are
trying to do
you cannot rely
on timing if you're trying to do things
that are really small interval I went at
this problem with stupidity I'll put it
out there I I went at this problem with
like I'm just going to try putting it at
a millisecond for every time that it
should fire and see what happens nope
that's not going to work that'll never
work and there's a reason why and that
goes back to script processing and Main
thread stuff where it like you it the
the Dom is being calculated and rendered
and you have all these other things that
are trying to get in there and so if you
try to schedule an event to happen and
and something else like your pages
rendering or whatever is going on at the
same time nope that's not going to
happen it's going to have to wait until
this point in time and then it can do it
so
um it's not going to it's that's just
the way it is and it's not going to be
accurate uh necessarily if you're going
down to a really small intervals of
trying to set timers for events but
it can be done accurately and the go-to
um
the uh the go-to uh a method for this in
the browser right now especially for
like live gaming and uh tools where
people want to do stuff with real-time
performance the best way to hook into
the browser with a um a Dependable uh
sample rate is by using the request
animation frame API and the reason is is
because it hooks into the refresh rate
of the browser which has to be as
constant as possible at 16 milliseconds
so if you can hook into that then you
can have you can get
pretty Dependable you know like it's
pretty Rock Solid I'll show you I'll
show you in a little bit
there are complications though with what
I'm doing that I'm like just discovering
as of like yesterday with request
animation frame and timers again I
thought I had gotten past this but
anyways that's one of the best ways
um so like how do you make sense of this
stuff anyways
um Observer observability right like you
need to hook into observability and
um be because like there's just no way
that uh you know you're gonna understand
uh like how long it took someone in like
with your real users how long it took
someone in
China are like in Beijing on an elevator
trying to load your app and then someone
in St Louis you know trying to load your
app uh in here with conference Wi-Fi and
then you know like whatever
it's like how do you know what the
latency was and if the performance so
like the only way you can really make
sense of this stuff is plugging in
observability
um because there's so many variables and
how the heck do you make sense of it all
anyways so
um so what I would suggest to you is to
tap into a tool like really user
monitoring so I don't I'm not this is
not like a datadoc plug just because I
work at daydog and they have a like an
awesome release or monitoring product I
mean you know
wowie's owie right you can just plug it
in and it's awesome but
I I've actually did a talk on this at
scale uh conference in La you can uh you
can definitely do an open source if you
want obviously there's a lot more
configuration and you don't if you don't
want to pay for a SAS product but you
can do it just to see what what's going
on with your users and tracking these
latencies well what's what's going to
get
um
oh yeah and I can show you right so when
we were doing all of that I had
datadog's real user monitoring plugged
in here and uh
so it was gathering all of the activity
um
that we were playing over that I'm not
scraping anything don't don't worry
about that I'm just this this is like
performance metrics for every user so
like hey when we all loaded the app
um you know there's there's these
Notions of things like larger of core
web vitals like where the vi where are
the vital components that made it
enjoyable there did it load fast all
that
um and then you know how many sessions
have I had but what gets more
interesting is if I if I dive further in
I can start to look at you know okay
cool we had a lot of different sessions
just not that long ago great awesome I'm
gonna dive in here and see what happened
and if any errors popped up or whatever
looks like this person uh mostly just
loaded it and I can see the the latency
of the events that happened and you know
like this kind of stuff if you're trying
to I'm not and I'm not just saying this
because I'm a data dog but if you're
trying to do something like this it's so
hard to get somewhere with this high of
a frequency of events that happen
without being able to understand like
before I mean my friend Nick must have
done something great because just before
this demo they were like 500 errors that
were popping down like on this thing so
like you know and if you if you upload
Source maps and that kind of stuff you
can get to the uh to the point uh as
close to the point of code where the
error happened occurred you can fix that
and you can fix your app before your
users experience the problem is is the
is the thing that I'm trying to show you
today so
um I don't I don't like trying to go
blind on it I want to be able to
um make this experience rad because
music you shouldn't be thinking about
what you're using while you're playing
music you should just be playing music
and so I think it's really pertinent to
this context
um so like with that like what else is
going to get in the way
um you know infrastructure is gonna is
gonna get in your way although there it
is 120 miles adds a millisecond of
latency to the average packet right so
infrastructure is going to be a problem
uh depending on where you are in the
world
um and how you want to handle that with
uh
uh with observability is distributed
synthetic performance testing so like
what I mean by that big word or whatever
but what I mean by that is synthetically
test your app in different regions with
websockets what you with a websocket app
what I'll need to do is uh deploy it to
servers in different regions and then
test the test the API calls around those
regions and see what the performance is
like in Ireland and in you know in uh
Central us and whatever to be able to
make sure that we're having as close to
a good experience as possible and that's
why synthetics is like super important
in that regard
okay
so that was kind of like an overview of
all the things that it kind of took to
to get to a point to where I can
probably have people play together
um still a lot of variables I'm
discovering every day and it's fun but
uh and that's the point right so what's
the current progress well first I'm
going to show you where I was at uh last
night with this and then after that uh
I'm gonna see if we're at a place to
where I can oh shoot to where I can have
um
my friend
test it out
oh
oh okay so maybe we'll just have to show
you this so um this is where we were at
last night with uh keyboardist and a
drummer
shoot I wish I
okay sorry you're gonna have to listen
to it through my keyboard unfortunately
um maybe I can pull my mic close to it
[Music]
thank you
okay so you know like this is just
testing right
so if we're not doing anything fancy or
interesting right now but what you can
see here is that he's my friend jove is
just like hitting his drum triggers
remotely and they're going into this
thing uh into this octopad thing that I
have here and uh and they are triggering
these notes you can see that again
[Music]
and then jump gets forward
foreign
so like as you can see there's been
progress and people are able to play in
time
just natural that's just natural time
there's there's no
uh uh there's no metronome
um that is somebody playing natural time
as somebody on the other side hearing it
playing along with it and then it coming
to us to hear rendered through uh those
those midi sounds I'll say those sounds
that sound like what we think of when we
think of midi
um but let me just see if this is um
let me see I I'd like at least want to
show you the app if I can I'm going to
see if it's uh if uh my friend Nick saw
this issue
um and take a look at it
so let me try that
okay there we go all right so let's just
see really quick and then uh I won't
keep it too long here
okay so I killed the server so I'm gonna
have to go back to the server I'm gonna
have to start that
and then after this we'll wrap up I know
I know we're getting we started late
we're ending late but I'll let you go
here in just a moment
okay
great
nope that's event mode
haha I didn't tell you that you could
switch modes
hey great my keyboard shows up okay
awesome okay so this is kind of the app
right now again I wish I had it plugged
in over there but uh maybe you can hear
it from here
um locations so when somebody shows up
you can see where they are I just
assigned them random fruit names for now
this I'm called Union Hackberry at the
moment uh and I am in St Louis and I
might get some information on that
um and what how these people are playing
those notes is that uh I can select you
know whatever uh instrument I want to
play so as we did before we can play via
the keyboard however if I want to choose
a midi source and play from you know
something like this
which it should hold on if I want to do
something like yeah so if I if I want to
play you know from a keyboard
so all that's possible right now in a
browser has been for a little while it
utilizes web midi another really cool
thing there are not the like vsts
I I want really good sounds because I'm
a musician right and vsts are
proprietary and I forgot about that I'm
like I'm gonna get vsts ready for this
thing nope sorry I can't because you
have to pay an arm and a leg for that
however there's a really cool project
called Web audio modules
um and there's and uh if you are into
building that kind of stuff please
please help them there's only a few
people doing it and it's a really
important thing you can get uh stuff
like um for through vsts I have a Yamaha
DX7 in here pretty much so like if I go
over to that and then I choose like you
know
was I don't know like mini Moog what's
that sound
this sounds very much like that you know
80s like whatever but if you're like
[Music]
you know like that kind of thing so like
you know if this were plugged into like
a system or whatever you could hear it
it sounds like exactly D7 there's cisx
dumps so midi uses sysex to system
exclusive messages to be able to get uh
these sounds
to save sounds import sounds that kind
of thing
um and there are there's like an archive
of like all the DX7 sysex dumps that you
can just grab from plop them in here and
load it so that's like super cool
there's an oberheim that I'm going to
put in here the like web audio module
that's great as well
um so if you choose that and then you
select uh
you select I think what I can demo
really quick is if I
select this drum pad here
and then uh let's see
and then I open up another window
let's say I want to okay
let's say I want to Output so I'm in
position one immune and Hackberry let's
say I want to Output to
the this role in SPD series thing and
I'm going to send that to an external
midi device well that's going to go to
the next player here
and they're going to receive it from a
device that's like that
and um
they're going to receive it from a
device that's like that and then they're
going to get it played on a device like
this so if all goes well this should
let's see
so on that player
and
um it could be my settings
uh I won't keep you but I had a I had a
video of this last night let's see
output to MIDI device right and then
input let's see input from midi Source
midi input is going to be that and then
um
yeah and so I should be able to hear it
or maybe I didn't um
browser stuff right like sometimes you
got to interact with the browser for it
to work
[Music]
okay
um okay I had it I had it last night
where just like this is position one
position two if you hit the notes then
it like I wanted to show you there's
five second delay and then they come
back
right and so that's what I was trying to
demonstrate here
um I'll post the video on on uh Twitter
so you can see it or whatever after this
but
um that's kind of what's going on is
that you can I I wanted you to be able
to hear that five second Gap and so it's
like I play and what's funny is if you
have like Zoom open or whatever you know
it's like you don't want to be looking
at zoom while you're trying to do this
because the play you know the players
are they're playing along and then
you're like
you start to feel like you're here in
about five seconds or whatever uh so
anyways yeah well um
thank you you know that's uh that's what
I have for you today so thank you so
much for joining me and I really
appreciate you staying long thank you so
much uh from above my heart for that and
uh we'll see you around please feel free
to get in contact with me anytime and
I'll post up to Twitter so you can see
it
[Applause]